okay so bunge jumping story um I like my
brother like just met his current wife
and she was like let's like go out and
like um do something fun yeah let's be
crazy and like you know those like uh
like popup theme parks that like pop up
randomly air well like I never thought
about this no it's a pop-up theme park
po I've never heard anybody call like a
Town Fair I'm different [__] I'm
Different you're Small Town Square
having the fair like yeah literally
never yeah to could never afford a popup
theme park um okay so there's this
pop-up theme park it's called like Six
Flags or something I don't know
something light little small nasty um so
we like go out to like I never thought
about this but like those like random
rides that just show up in your hometown
like got to like they have to live
somewhere yeah so like there's like a
base camp of these like rides in Fort
Worth Dallas they were like let's go
like let's go have a blast and I was
like sure like that actually sounds fun
um and we pull up and it had just rained
and everything was wet and it like was
like a actual rust bucket like it was
horrifying like it was so scary and like
you have to buy tickets and they're
really really [__] expensive like
$505 each to like go ride like two rides
and like we get in and how much 55 each
oh that's expensive to you that's weird
yeah I don't have it like that bro I
don't have it like that um but so
they're like really really it's it's not
a Vibe at all like when you walk in it's
not like what you're thinking it's
literally like they're just like erected
there yeah um like they don't have any
RAR reason and then we just like kind of
do all these like silly little rides but
then I'm like I want a bungee jump and
so me and my twin sister we like hike up
the thing and we're standing there yeah
we're like it's like cuz you have to
climb like ladders and stairs to get up
that's how like nasty it is um and so
yeah stairs
I only ride elevators and escalators
like you know that like we're going to
have to get one inall you know that
about me yeah so we get up there they
put the harnesses on and they're like
attaching it to my ankles but they like
put mateline in like the like f the like
the harness harness yeah like where you
sit down and like I'm standing there and
I'm like wait are they like going to
make me dive off of this [__] because
like I've never done this and I'm not
doing that like that does not sound like
a Vibe at all we're over the edge and
I'm like oh I'm going to be big bro and
like go first and then like my brain and
body like literally were fully
disconnected in the craziest way like
legitimately like like your [__] head
hit the P dud I know literally literally
literally it's like fully disconnected
and I'm like I'm telling my body to jump
but my body is like Frozen and I can't
do it so I'm like begging the guy I'm
like please push me off please push me
off like please and he's like I can't do
that cuz if you die like it's on me bro
but long story short mine goes before me
I jump off and the video is the most
insane thing ever I literally like
scorpion so like my Fe like it I have
like permanent back damage from it you
talked about was like my neck my neck
dude it's like I still am like bodied
from it I had to go to like chiropracty
with like a chiropractor for like 3
years which like I don't know if I
believe in chiropracty anymore cuz it
didn't do [__] for me but uh yeah it
[__] me up like permanently and the
video is hilarious is the video out
there yes oh let's pull it up you can
literally look up Philips bungee jumping
and I've never seen anybody's body do
that when they're bungee jumping like I
can't wait you have so much fluidity
yeah I'm like really bendy and stretchy
I mean that's he went for twerking and
all that so that's true true he had like
a lot of practice for stuff like that
it's easy for
me I have to I have to commend you for
walking into a theme park like that and
saying yeah I'm down a bungee jump
that's what I'm saying you just called
it a rust bucket and then you're like oh
I'm going to go on the most dangerous
thing here I'm brave
I'm a warrior yeah oh wow you are a
soldier You're A Soldier of Love
soldiers of love he has to sing that to
let you know he's really about it dude
no he's singing it because like do we
will never ever show this publicly but
we do an annual secret santa every year
with our like main friend group and we
did all the gifts and we're sitting
there and Josh Josie and Drew are like
okay now everybody close your eyes we
have like a final gift and I didn't know
what I expected I actually didn't expect
I expected t-shirts cuz we've gotten
like everybody t-shirts before so I was
like okay they got a t-shirt printed and
then they were like open your eyes also
they didn't put any of the gifts in our
lap so all of us opened our eyes and
we're like actually looking around cuz
we didn't know what we were looking for
um and there were just these CDs placed
in front of us and they had made an
album together the past year and it's
like went crazy the worst but the best
thing I've ever heard no it's like
actually like there's some really like
artistic moment moments on this album
like it's it's actually really special
and advanced um but yeah it's like
horrible I will say it is like MF do
Doom like rolled in his grave a little
he's like [__] like there's already a
prodigy out there like taking my mark OG
Outcast OG Outcast Drew Phillips bungee
jumping this is it this oh [__] all
right first off stop dude that's not a b
that is a crane yeah you went you went
to a construction site you paid 60 bucks
to go to a construction site and they're
like no yeah we got rides
this dude's in an
excavator what sucks is like the pad
that you land in was like literally a
pond like it was like a p dude there's
no also there's no sight of it in this
video like there's no safety nets
there's nothing dude you jumped off this
you're you are a warrior bro you should
be fighting in the UFC you're insane
thank you bro yeah run
this oh bro yeah so look that's where it
all goes
wrong you could Su dude I know I thought
about it like my blood vessels and my
eyes were like exploded like my neck
like was all [__] up your ey blown I'm
like in permanent like immediate
Rigamortis like I'm like stiff
immediately like and then I get lowered
into a pond it was like pure torture I
could if you hit that little bounce pad
you fully would have flown off like that
was like not the like dude do it again
so like the problem is is when I go up
in the air like the cable wasn't like
the right side so pause right there like
I'm like I'm like vertical and then I
fall down and just get like Whiplash and
I'm flexing every muscle in my body like
I'm David do piloting this thingal
[__] dude it was David who pushed you
yeah yeah David was operating the
crane yeah no it was crazy it was
actually a part of his sponsored post
for rayb band so David has the POV of
yeah yeah he won't let me release it he
used it as evidence in the
court dude back it up and press play I
got to see your body just fully Get
Wrecked again that dude that moment that
moment my neck hurts looking at that you
can look at me you 100% I signed like 36
waivers so I literally don't know if I
could like we walked up and signed like
liability waivers after seeing this [__]
like insane Behavior were your eye
vessels actually blown out in your eyes
dude they were like popped like it was
crazy I didn't have like red eyes but
you know like when one or two is just
kind like bleeding out like yeah it was
it was crazy you know just like when one
or two or you know what's crazy is like
I remember like when I like was flapping
back and forth like my vision went black
because like all of the blood rushed out
of my brain like and that's why I am the
way I am also like you telling me that
like I would have never thought to I
just like oh my God you look so stupid
yeah it was crazy but yeah that's my bu
upside down says the actions in this
video are performed by professionals oh
yeah classic I actually went to school
for bunging jumping as well yeah as
well you think you'd ever do this again
bu jumping yes I actually would that I
legitimately would I want to jump out of
an airplane like really really B
parachute just go yeah no I'm like
suicidal it's giving suicide I'm glad
you're in his life I told him I was like
he tried to confess it to me like in the
safety of our home and I was like listen
this is a public matter you need to tell
the public this like this is not my
business talk about it on this podcast I
was like your mental health is not my
issue you need to make that public would
y'all jump out of an airplane with a
parachute um absolutely not I think on
like a certain day I could mhm but it's
not it's not like up there for me yeah I
saw this video of like these people like
having a trampoline underneath a hot air
balloon and they were like jumping on
the trampoline and like doing back flips
off like why did I see that and think
like oh that's kind of like lit like I
could do that when you couldn't even
keep your body like that's not my fault
that was not my fault no I'm going to
victim blame you that's all
you